the world needs him
[Music]
godzilla
all right
right now godzilla is out there and he's
hurting people we don't know why
we need kong
[Music]
the world needs him
[Music]
there can't be two alpha titans
in theaters and on hbo max march 31st
rated pg-13
these are dangerous times we need khan
the world needs him
two of these classic monsters are going
head-to-head
that's really so exciting it is a
spectacle it's
unlike anything you've ever seen but the
beauty of this particular story is the
different storylines on every character
he needs our help there must be some way
to disorient godzilla
you can look at the film as two separate
stories that
intersect eventually team kong and team
godzilla each human story is following
the monster story as well
we believe that they have an ancient
rivalry the myths say that their
ancestors fought each other in a great
war
team khan you have alexander skarsgard
kaylee hoddle and
rebecca hall they're there really to
support kong and his
fight with godzilla the stakes are high
and it's a very risky
operation but we have to go through with
it all right matt how to
down the rabbit hole on the other end of
the journey we have
team godzilla millie bobby brown brian
tyree henry and
jillian dennison they're basically on
this adventure to try
find out why godzilla is attacking
they're trying to put two and two
together to figure out why is this going
on
they're an amazing team they complement
each other so well to be a part of that
team is great just trying to figure out
how to actually
understand godzilla rather than trying
to destroy him
we always saw the movie as being
separated between team godzilla and team
kong
and that was exciting to me doing this
movie team con
or godzilla i'm a kung guy
i don't know i got a root for kong hard
for me to
choose but as a japanese person godzilla
i like king kong because he's a giant
monkey and monkey's call
100 team car i'm not picking sides
you don't really want to pick a side
crown i gotta pick a side team goes a
little fast
you